it's the thickest and oldest ice in the
Arctic scientists thought it would be
the last to withstand the effects of a
hotter planet but it's starting to break
apart twice this year the waters around
North Greenland have opened up waters
that are normally frozen even in summer
this part of Greenland is typically
northern part of Greenland it's usually
very cold it's usually got a lot of sea
ice there that can be 3 or 4 metres
thick it looks like the sea ice we have
this year is quite a lot thinner so
that's quite unusual and not really what
we expected to see so early
these satellite images show how since
the start of the year ice has been
pushed away from the coast high winds
and warmer temperatures mean the ice has
retreated the most since records began
40 years ago and this graph shows how
much the volume of the Arctic sea ice
has fallen more than 60% in the last 30
years
dropping to its lowest point this year
this could threaten the very survival of
the region's most iconic inhabitants and
also create opportunity for others it's
a very rare event so in that sense the
possibility to have the entirety of the
of Greenland circumcircle navigable is
very rare the early polar explorers
explorers for example could not reach
these regions because they were closed
by sea ice the Arctic is the fastest
warming place on the planet providing
the first indication of how climate
change is having an impact and it's
happening much earlier than expected
Charlotte Lomas Sky News